now we are centered okay Jesus
OCD happy to be here though huh time for
Rita Jess for Tara prejack nation oh my
god I have something to tell you tell
him your name Tara hi guys I'm Tarek
s'en has returned first female guest of
2020 actually boom shot
I was asking Tara if she's ever heard of
this channel new rock stars and I'm
telling you whatever reaction I gave
before we record it was so much bigger
than whatever I'll give him this video
she's like yeah I've been on it I was
like what you been on new rock stars
like one of my favorite channels I typed
her name and she was totally on one of
the rogue theory episodes marble face
for death of the MCU blew my mind I
can't believe she's been on it
and no matter how many times we react to
their videos they don't care about oh
you don't know me I was on the new rule
Channel and now I'm on don't real
rejects Channel except real rejects
found me first that's right you guys to
me before you wouldn't have found her if
it wasn't for the real rejects that's
probably true though Tara likes to talk
talking Tara calm tell them about it
it's my new blog you guys should go read
about it I talked about life looks love
and a little bit fun I'm also gonna
start posting my reviews and articles
for movies and TVs on there too so you
guys should go check it out as soon as
you can oh yeah we're watching this one
division breakdown like we promised we
would let's do it okay teaser is part of
the Marvel these people a Super Bowl
spot another upcoming series like Loki
most worthy abstain I understood that
reference I look at things the Avenger
with powers so forgettable even her
accident is forgotten it's getting a
makeover to restore the character to be
nice swapping abilities in the comics
very true decode this footage and piece
together how I think this bonkers series
will play out when it comes out later
this year now I covered the Falcon
Winter Soldier footage in another video
but it's a great video gonna watch you
guys in case my Wanda vision predictions
end up being too accurate and ruin your
life let's roll the clip Wanda Maximoff
in vision and a handful of sitcom
realities varying by the amount of
Technicolor hairspray and waist height
and then resolves a lip clip from the
end of the trailer okay
let's start breaking down all of the
water vision replicas here there's one
black and white sitcom reality
apparently based on classic fifties
sitcoms like I Love Lucy honeymooners
I'm gonna guess I Love Lucy because I
expect vision will be less likely to
bring a little wonder on and the
headpiece is clearly cardboard so this
is obviously meant to be a costume in
context here like one a sitcom character
would wear on a Halloween episode so I'm
wondering if this reality could be like
you sixties sitcom bewitched with Wanda
in seventies attire in here similar to
Marcia Brady from The Brady Bunch
we have that kind of stares if the Brady
Bunch set had also worth noting that
Wanda is pregnant in this show are born
because they're standing in front of two
cribs with the babies adorably spitting
out their past no idea her older twin
sisters who got their start as the twin
babies not cool house but yes there is a
deeper story to one this
kids get to that this well next there's
no shot chilly Wanda in plaid no girls
big hair in front of a kitchen bridge
covered in children's art one has a
leather bean I believe could be for
Billy Kaplan aka the Marvel meet Wiccan
who is kinder one this kid along with
the twin brother speed
Tommy Shepard looks me in mom mode here
crap sperm a 96 hums showing
middle-class families like Roseanne
married with children and lastly there's
a shot of I am rose on the fifties TV
sets which could switched off as present
day wanna struggles to keep her balance
completely thrown by the fact that she
is trapped in this black-and-white
Pleasantville type reality now based on
all of these clues I think we have a
pretty decent idea of what this could
look like in terms of episodes fine
before we get to that like Wanda
Maximoff
I often buy Broadway's I'm confused by
my own clothing which sometimes you may
have noticed switches abruptly mid video
so in an attempt to expand my wardrobe
happens I have frustrated shopping
online because I always find out about
those coupon codes right after I buy
something great I think we're Bertram
honey monitoring this breakdown
I mean we've definitely worked with
money will work with honey again do your
cards takes two clicks to install when
you check out this little box drops down
and all you have to do is click whenever
a does the product placements he always
makes it sound like he found them and
asked them to sponsor the video okay
look you know what this life issue and
then I came across these guys and now
they're sponsoring they've already saved
themselves over two hundred thousand
dollars collectively you to welcome and
you thought I was only helping you win
nerdy arguments with your
[Laughter]
- clicks so get honey or free at join
honey complex new rock star what if our
link is still active time fly users
here's my theory for this season of
Wanda vision for kind of Maximus Carly
which is known for her reality altering
powers which is best known for from the
house of M comic series and that
storyline Wanda loses her mind and
chaotically resets reality uber uber
again swapping in and out of alternate
universes some of which she has two
mutant children and later on in the
Marvel comic - su kids were revealed as
Wiccan and speed long-lost twin brothers
they initially banished from existence
but then like their souls were
reinserted and the new bodies some
people think and because perhaps anyway
I think one division in adapting house
of m would want a maxima grieving over
visions death in the war against Thanos
and that grieve manifesting into Wanda
living her dream family life with vision
through various hypothetical sitcom
realities the season could look like
shows like mr. robot or Legion which
featured mentally unhinged heroes
bending John's Wanda gesture in and out
of a very big fan personal life wit
vision appears to progress through the
decades newlyweds in I Love Lucy married
life and bewitched early pregnancy and
the Brady Bunch
new parents raising young kids breakdown
Roseanne perhaps this will open with
waters transporting her consciousness
into visions Android corpse and like an
attempt to resurrected but then what
would see is a grieving Wanda's
consciousness navigating the
complexities of visions mind which
remember is robotic and composed of data
inputs inputs like twentieth-century
television so her arrival in this
bizarre reality would begin with Wanda
and her normal clothes but in color
landing in a black and white universe
because remember when vision died he D
saturated into his soul by the end of it
we may not be vision back foot perhaps
the result of Wanda's reality Bundy
journey could be a manifestation of
twins
Witkin in speed officially introducing
mutants to the MCU right - MCU x-men
finally a number of MCO co-stars have
been confirmed for this series kat
dennings is returning from night
as Darcy Lewis to Anna Paris is playing
an adult version of Monica Rambeau
granular coming back is agent Wu format
man in the wine is joining the MCU and
I'm having to nosy neighbor they could
imagine each of these characters
populating a different sitcom reality
like they'd be capping on could be a
Wilson Kevin Feige is also in genetic
cameo from Sparky the dog from the Tom
King vision comics which religion is
that oh it's gonna be such a cool show
it's totally possible that one of
Wanda's dream realities could feature
her brother Quicksilver still alive
would be crashing at her place in the
full house reality haha we gotta help
raising these girls with his wife's
brother and also with his best friend
hey old comedian Marvel trailers dropped
during the Superbowl the first thing I
did was jump on new rock stars official
discord to chat with our inner circle
nerds lately it's been really my go-to
place for theories and hot takes and
stuff that's just like two out there too
real for the videos here on youtube for
exclusive access to our new rock stars
discord please consider becoming a
patron of new rock stars today at
patreon.com I don't want patrons not
that which I want is alternate sitcom
realities are you most excited for
family down below with your thoughts
roseann footage follow me @e a box
follow new rock stars and social media
and subscribe to new rock stars for all
of our Marvel breakdowns thanks for
watching woo Lucy great video I would
first like to say that I love the hell
out of this video like new rock stars
sometimes what they do they'll reach you
know like they'll find a little tiny
thing and they'll do like a minute
breakdown of it and I'm like that's a
bit of a stretch but there were things
in here in that 30-second spot it's
fascinating to me that they were able to
pick up on so many little things just by
really slowing down the frames because
I've seen that big game spot on my own
several times and I never noticed the
pacifiers flying up in the air I never
noticed the baby bump that's why new
rock stars has never invited me on for
some reason has invited Tara Onslow I
gotta ask you Tara
slow what were they like in person does
Aaron Voss look as tired in person as he
does in some videos it's always dark
circles under his eyes
but they're nice very nice
oh that's so cool now we got to become
closer terror they even showed me where
the bathroom was
they even watch me go to the bathroom
yeah
very considerate really mean too but
I'll take the company no so nice well
I'm excited for this man I out of the
three shows this is the one I've been
the most intrigued by just because they
kept saying how weird and different it's
going to be sometimes I disagree with
their theories but their theory I think
the evidence they provided for it seems
to back it up Wanda trying to go into
visions consciousness and explores my my
question is though is just aesthetically
why she's imagining these family
scenarios to be my classic sitcoms or
was Wanda secretly a huge sitcom founded
Wanda have a Netflix account and on her
cue was it only shows like I Love Lucy
and Rosa and the whole time like why is
it these sitcoms specifically is that
visions mind who is fishing a huge
sitcom fan and we just had no idea about
these things but which one are you most
excited for I think it's because she
might be a fan aesthetically I guess
they all match up as a parody of all
those sitcoms I don't know maybe she had
a Netflix queue yeah I don't think so I
think it's the aesthetics of it but I
think it's gonna play out as a parody of
all those shows that they mentioned my
favorite is the I Love Lucy only because
it would put her in a place to do a lot
of physical comedy
I would hope please bring physical
comedy to that if you're actually doing
callback to I Love Lucy
you better be stepping in grapes falling
all around shoving tons of chocolate in
your mouth and trying to say words you
should just be I just want to see a
shot-for-shot reboot of I Love Lucy
that's exactly what I'm saying that's it
the whole time I think it's so
fascinating what they're doing they are
saying that this shows was the segue
into Doctor Strange to multiverse of
madness and she's going to be in that
Doctor Strange movie so it seems like
out of all the shows that are coming out
this will probably have the most effect
in terms of the progression of how even
the movies play out if that makes sense
and their theory of the kids of how
they're probably be mutants of how that
can open up the door for x-men now
they're with Disney this video little
literally got me super duper excited
usually new rock stars videos like I've
always find them intriguing sometimes
the Easter eggs are a lot of fun but
this video really succeeded in getting
me excited for what is potentially
unlikely to come in the future I just
love that the kids in the comic book
from their little babies they both have
brown hair and then we attorney mutants
one of them has just straight-up
white hair like are you adopted speed or
are you not because you do not look like
wicked they're mutants they're freaks
how it works Toria I'm just waiting for
the day I wake up and I got white hair
and then I know I just put here to do
weird stuff what's funny how much what's
your goals huh
you don't wake up halfway here wait what
do you what do you want I think what I
have gray hair and a great beard Tara I
want to be a sexy Silver Fox
wow really real annemun huh there's an
Instagram account of a male model uh-huh
who actually he's our age and he dyes
his hair to make him look old I just
fell asleep sorry continue
if you're gonna insult me in my home you
can sleep tend to suddenly take interest
in this thing that I find interesting
okay finding interesting how old is this
kid dyeing his hair to look older is he
like 25 trying to reel in that like you
know you're like multiple personality
syndrome there's a time where I thought
you just had like a bunch of improv
graded just chill out at any moment
now I'm under the impression you're just
truly delusional you're hearing
something when the bell rings do a new
character because people find the silver
fox attractive that's what it is and I'm
gonna be that guy there is no way he's
walking around with white hair and he
does admitted to it I forget the name of
the guy we're getting way too off track
here
it's scammer hey you brought it up I
fell asleep you are the most yeah what's
the word I'm look at Rick outrageous Wow
we can't say that we can't say I feel
like that's fun and weird as this show
is looking to be because of the fact
that it's dealing probably with going
into visions consciousness and trying to
revive him back to life and dealing with
the themes of grief that the surprise
would be a pretty emotional and
heartbreaking show simultaneously yeah
especially if she's the one accessing
his mind to try to get him back and to
live in the consciousness of the way she
envisioned her life with him it's gonna
be sad to see it if that's not reality
if that's just you know her subconscious
intertwining with his and at the end of
it she's still left with a dead vision
sad sad sub reality is what it is do you
behave this way
haven't seen your video rockstars Jesus
when you were on there you should go
check out the video guys that's what
we're trying to tell you yeah yeah I
don't know what I do on there I think
I'd probably speak normally and
professionally and respectfully in
respectfully but let me tell you this
right here okay
this query album deserve quickly album
my respect here I mean surrounded my
trial manager stuffing white boards with
post stuff do this do that you know it's
like ah it's too much I try to just come
in here live in a topple well guys what
do you think of one division leave your
thoughts down below leave them we're not
talking Tara calm go check out her blog
she also has a YouTube channel which has
some of the most unique reactions you'll
ever see go check it out I got subscribe
please and thank you thank you do the
same thing for our channel as well
that's that tumor again it's coming back
oh listen this with a patron of the days
shut up JN Valente JN Valente I wanted
to shout you out specifically in this
Wanda vision video because I feel like I
go through many different alternate
realities and find our way back to the
point where you would converse with me
all the time you haven't left our
patreon page so you have stayed in our
hearts and our minds throughout this
entire process yet I feel like for the
longest time I've been searching for you
trying to connect with you going around
many different portals through our
patreon just trying to get in touch with
JN Valente and one day JN Valente will
talk back with me and we will have our
stream of consciousness conversations
all over again
rum like what is J and talking about how
do I respond to this let me pick a
sentence okay I'll go with that
JN has a beautiful jazz like approach to
the way he articulates in the written
form
it's like talking with Nicolas Cage's
son who like competent a Nicholas Cage
believe it or not there's probably more
consistent very least yeah and that's
you
you're Nicolas Cage's you're consistent
Nicolas key or the color out of space my
friend